la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle à la discussion de la
proposition de loi visant la reprise en
charge par l'État de l'accompagnement
humain des élèves en situation de
handicap sur le temps méridien présenté
par Monsieur Cédric Vial et plusieurs de
ses collègues dans la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur sédic
Vial auteur de la proposition de loi
pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
si
j'arrive ça
marche
bien monsieur monsieur le Président
Madame madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues en être
devant vous ce soir constitue pour moi à
la fois un plaisir un aboutissement un
honneur une étape et une satisfaction un
plaisir tout d'abord puisque c'est ma
proposition de loi un sujet que je porte
depuis près d'un an maintenant avec avec
conviction et donc c'est toujours un
moment
important dans la vie d'un parlementaire
en tout cas j'imagine que d'avoir son
projet débattu en hémicycle c'est un
aboutissement car c'est à la suite de la
mission flash que j'ai mené sur les
modalités de question des
accompagnateurs d'enfants situation du
handicap et pour une école inclusive qui
est apparu la nécessité de passer par la
loi pour résoudre un certain nombre de
problèmes et il s'agit donc là ce soir
de la traduction de la recommandation
numéro 10 de ce rapport que j'avais
porté au nom de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation j'en profite
pour remercier son son président Laurent
Laffond c'est un honneur un honneur car
vous avez été très nombreux de tous les
bords politiques à encourager et à
soutenir cette initiative jusqu'à un
vote unanime en commission de la culture
et de l'éducation et j'espère que vous
serez ce soir à la hauteur de votre vote
en
commission c'est aussi une étape car si
vous décidez de voter ce texte ce soir
il conviendra ensuite de lui permettre
de poursuivre sa route à l'Assemblée
nationale avec je le souhaite le regard
bienveillant du gouvernement qui serait
en tous les cas un atout indéniable
pour pour faire de ce texte une avancée
c'est une satisfaction aussi car il
s'agit d'une loi
simple on ne peut plus
simple mais qui réglera des problèmes
devenus complexes et des problèmes qui
n'existaient pas avant d'ailleurs que
l'État ne les
crée donc pourquoi en sommes-nous
arrivriver là je voudrais sans refaire
l'histoire vous rappeler quand même
quelques étapes tout d'abord la loi de
de 2005 de février 2005 vous étiez
ministre à l'époque dans le
gouvernement de de l'époque qui a misise
en œuvre cette loi sous l'impulsion du
président de de la République Jacques
Chirac qui a été une avancée importante
un grand pas en avant dans la prise en
charge des politiques en direction du
handicap et qui a permis notamment de
garantir le droit à la scolarisation de
passer d'une obligation éducative à une
obligation de scolarisation de de tous
les enfants en situation de handicap
dans un établissement en milieu
ordinaire le plus près de chez eux c'est
une première étape qui n'a jamais
ensuite été démenti qui a même été
confirmé par la loi de de
2013 dans le gouvernement sous sous la
présidence du gouvernement Hollande de
la loi pour la refondation de l'école
cette cette loi de cette loi de 2013 qui
là aussi a permis une avancée
supplémentaire et qui a permis notamment
la création des aesh des fameux
accompagnateur d'enfants en situation de
de handicap depuis 2005 puis depuis
2013 qui et 2013 qui qui inscrit dans le
marbre la la le concept d'inclusion
scolaire il ne s'est jamais démenti
qu'on a toutes les pot les politiques
publiques ont mis en œuvre euh tout ce
qui pouvait faciliter cette inclusion
scolaire le code de l'éducation dispose
d'ailleurs euh de de manière de manière
très claire mais c'est celui-là que j'ai
perdu le le code d'éducation dispose
d'ailleurs de de manière très claire que
il revient à l'état de mettre en œuvre
tous les moyens qui concourent à la
scolarisation de de d'un enfant en
situation de handicap qu'il soit enfant
adolescents ou ou adules adules
handicapé euh
et pourtant après ces deux grands pas en
avant il y a eu un pas en arrière c'est
cette décision du Conseil d'État qui
date de novembre 2020 qui est
venu à contrecourant de ce qui avait été
admis par tous les gouvernements
successifs et tous les parlements
successifs depuis cette loi de de
2005 remettre en cause remettre en cause
ce ce dispositif qui permettait cette
inclusion en jugeant que le législateur
s'était probablement trompé en en
souhaitant que la prise en charge sur le
temps méridien était nécessaire à
l'inclusion scolaire et pourtant elle
l'est n nous avons
donc besoin aujourd'hui par la loi de
rétablir ce qui n'aurait de mon point de
vue jamais dû être remis en remis en
cause par une
jurisprudence redire par la loi ce que
le législateur a toujours souhaité faire
ce que les gouvernements avaiit toujours
appliqué jusque- là c'est-à-dire queol
pour scolariser un enfant en situation
de handicap le le fait de de pouvoir
l'accompagner sur le temps méridien
était nécessaire et c'est cette
nécessité qui qui qui s'impose à l'état
euh c'est une responsabilité qui
s'impose à l'état et donc cette loi
finalement permet
juste de de rappeler au juges que c'est
le Parlement qui fait la loi et que ce
n'est pas la jurisprudence qui qui qui
l'a fait donc il y a rien finalement de
nouveau et pourtant depuis
2020 cette jurisprudence a a créé un
certain nombre de de difficultés un
certain nombre de problème je vous dis
complexe comme si la vie des parents
d'enfants en situation handicap n'était
pas suffisamment complexe comme cela
alors donner un interlocuteur
supplémentaire à
leur demander des des démarches
supplémentaires et à créer des des
effets de bord
probablement non non prévu non souhaité
mais devenu
considérable le le premier le premier
effet c'est la rupture de la prise en
charge de ces enfants en situation de
handicap rappelons-nous pourquoi nous
faisons tout ça pourquoi nous avons mis
en place cette politique c'est pour
permettre aux enfants de en situation de
handicap de de vivre une scolarité la
plus normale possible par des mesures de
de d'accessibilité quand c'est possible
et de compensation de compensation
humaine quand cela est nécessaire cette
r cette rupture d'accompagnement
éducatif avec notamment des changements
d'interlocuteur quand quand une un
accompagnement restait mise en place sur
le temps méridien euh était une vraie
difficulté subie par certains enfants
notamment on pense tous aux enfants en
situation de trouble autistique mais
mais bien au-delà ça ça conduit aussi à
des difficultés de prise en charge pour
les collectivités territoriales à qui on
a
euh transmis finalement cette
responsabilité avec un coût financier
évidemment très difficile à supporter
pour certaines communes rurales mais
au-delà du de de ce cout on pense aussi
à la responsabilité de dans dans des
communes qui n'ont pas de compétenence
jusqu'à présent en matière de handicap
qui n'avait pas de capacité de jugement
si l'enfant avait besoin d'être
accompagné ou pas et alors que les MDPH
ne notifiaent plus sur le temps méridien
une on laissait les maires devant une
responsabilité lourde probablement trop
lourde pour eux et un et un coût pour la
collectivité qui n'était de notre point
de vue pas celui que le législateur
souhaitait leur confier troème troisème
difficulté c'était pour les les
l'enseignement privé qui eux n'avaient
pas la non'ont pas la la possibilité ou
la capacité ou l'obligation en tous les
cas d'être financé par les collectivités
territoriales sielles ne sont plus
financées par l'État n'avit pas non plus
la possibilité de financer par leur leur
financement habituel c'estàdire le
forfait scolaire le le coût de de ces
personnels sur le temps méridien et cela
a conduit à des difficultés importantes
de déscolarisation d'enfants dans
certains cas à avec une rescolarisation
quand c'était possible dans des
établissements publics voisins
avec le recours à des solutions qui
relèvent du système D qu'on devrait pas
connaître dans notre à notre époque avec
du recours à du bénévola ou pour éviter
toute
vague un financement qui a perduré par
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale
malgré la décision du du Conseil d'État
une troisème conséquence concerne les
les aesh eux-mêmes qui se retrouve très
souvent aussi dans dans un dans dans un
souhait de de pouvoir professionnaliser
le le le leur métier mais comment prof
comment faire en sorte que aesh soit un
vrai métier quand on on est sur des des
temps partiels ou très partiel euh quand
on est sur des multiontrats avec
plusieurs employeurs là là aussi il
était nécessaire de de permettre à ces
aesag d'avoir un contrat unique euh
d'avoir un employeur unique
d'avoir aussi une une formation adaptée
à à leur métier à cette prise en charge
et le cette décision du Conseil d'État
remettait là aussi en cause beaucoup de
ces possibilités et malgré les avancées
que constituait la circulaire la
circulaire du du 4 janvier 2023 on s'est
aperçu qu'elle était finalement peu
appliquée c'est une autre question mais
on pourrait se ce que qu'on pourrait se
poser sur le l'applicabilité des
décisions prises par le ministère de
ucation nationale sans vouloir être plus
long parce que j'ai dit que ce texte
était simple et qu'il réglait un certain
nombre de problèmes et de problèmes
compliqués euh il ne réglera pas tous
les problèmes évidemment que le le le
sujet de l'inclusion scolaire mérite et
méritera malgré les moyens qui ont été
mis en place qu'on revoie de font en
combe l'organisation néanmoins c'est une
première étape qu'on vous propose
aujourd'hui pour régler de manière
simple des problèmes compliqué je crois
que nous sommes attendus par beaucoup
par par beaucoup d'associations par par
beaucoup d'enseignants par beaucoup d'
par beaucoup d'enfants j'espère que nous
serons au rendez-vous ce soir que que la
petique d'inclusion scolaire nous a fixé
je vous remercie
merci merci la parole est à Madame Anne
Ventalon rapporteur de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation de la
communication et du sport pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission de la culture chers collègues
aucune institution n'incarne mieux la la
promesse républicaine que l'école à
condition de veiller à ce qu'elle assume
ses valeurs d'égalité et de fraternité
gravées sur les frontons de nos
établissements scolaires c'est pourquoi
l'école inclusive fait l'objet d'une
attention particulière et ancienne de
notre commission aussi je remercie
Cédric Vial de nous avoir donné
l'opportunité d'en débattre grâce à
l'examen de sa proposition de loi vis la
prise en charge par l'État de
l'accompagnement humain des élèves en
situation de handicap sur le temps
méridien la dernière fois que nous avons
abordé le sujet avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'était en
novembre dernier dans un tout autre
contexte sur tous les bans de notre
assemblée nous avions dénoncé la volonté
du gouvernement de transformer les pôles
inclusifs d'accompagnement localisé les
piales en pôle d'appui à la scolarité
cette réforme pourtant Sy
se faisait sans concertation et en
catiminiie lors du débat budgétaire la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui ne réglera bien sûr pas elle
seule l'ensemble des problématiques
auxquelles l'école inclusive doit faire
face mais elle constitue une première
étape elle vise à garantir une
continuité tout au long de la journée
dans la prise en charge des élèves en
situation de handicap
scolarisé combien d'enfants ont besoin
en accompagnement humain sur le temps
méridien répondre avec précision à cette
question nécessiterait des données
exhaustives qui hélas font défaut
l'ordre de grandeur qui m'a été donné
par les services du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de 20000 à
25000 élèves concernés en 2023 une
estimation sans doute basse ce sont en
tout cas plusieurs milliers d'enfants et
leurs familles qui ont été perturbés par
la décision du Conseil d'État du 20
novembre 2020 en effet celui-ci a
considéré que la compétence de l'État se
restreint à la prise en charge des
situations de handicap sur la seule
période scolaire les temps périscolaires
incluant le passage à la cantine relève
de la responsabilité des collectivités
territoriales cette décision a modifié
la prise en charge financière et
administrative des aesage sur le temps
méridien à rebour de la pratique en
vigueur la nouvelle situation a fait
deux perdants les élèves et leur
accompagnatrices ces ces aesages qui
sont principalement des femmes ont en
effet vu leur emploi du temps malmené
neont ne pouvant plus travailler pour
l'éducation nationale sur le temps
péréscolaire surtout elle se retrouve à
présent avec deux employeurs l'État pour
le temps scolaire et la commune pour le
temps périscolaire
elles enchaînent ainsi les heures sans
pause règlementaires de 20 minutes à
midi ou sans prise en compte des temps
de trajet lorsqu'elles sont affectées
l'après-midi dans un autre établissement
les communes ont dû assumer une charge
vianciire supplémentaire et ce dans un
contexte budgétaire contraint elles
doivent également exercer une compétence
qui n'est pas de leur ressort et peuvent
ainsi avoir des difficultés pour
identifier la bonne personne à recruter
enfin certains élèves en situation de
handicap se retrouve sans accompagnement
sur le temps méridien malgré les
recommandations de la la Maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
d'ailleurs afin d'éviter de mettre en
difficulté des élèves jusquici
accompagné à la cantine avec une prise
en charge de l'État les personnels de
l'Éducation nationale ont eu pour
consigne de ne pas remettre en cause les
situations existantes madame la ministre
le ministère m'a indiqué continuer à
financer 60 % des besoins
d'accompagnement sur le temps
périscolaire bien évidemment je salue
cette décision de ne pas retirer du jour
au lendemain son accompagnant à à un
élève mais qu'en est-il des 40 %
restants car cette décision du Conseil
d'État entraîne des différences de
traitement je pense notamment aux élèves
du premer degré à l'exception de ceux
déjà accompagnés en 2020 la prise en
charge de l'accompagnement humain sur le
temps méridien dépend des capacités de
la commune pour le second degré en
revanche c'est l'État qui continue de
financer je pense également aux élèves
en situation de handicap scolarisé dans
les établissements privés sous contrat
le forfait scolaire ne permet pas de
couvrir les dépenses qui interviennent
sur le temps péréscolaire contraignant
les établissements à faire appel à des
volontaires des parents des
grands-parents ou des enseignants
retraités parfois des aesage sont
présents sans refacturation par le
rectorat et la question de la
responsabilité en cas d'accident du
travail est passer sous silence enfin
l'absence de solution a aussi
malheureusement conduit s parents à
devoir retirer leur enfant de
l'établissement face à ces situations et
aux nombreuses questions des communes
quelle a été la réponse du ministère une
note adressée au recteur le 4 janvier
2003 a rappelé des trois modalités pour
l'organisation de la prise en charge des
élèves handicapés pendant la pause
méridienne le recrutement direct par la
collectivité territoriale le recrutement
en commun et la mise à disposition par
l'Éducation nationale d'AES volontaire
aux collectivités territoriales
reconnaissons-le la mise à disposition
représente un progrès elle permet de
réduire le nombre d'employeurs des aesh
et d'améliorer leurs conditions de
travail permettant aussi une vraie
continuité dans le suivi des élèves en
situation de handicap néanmoins elle
reste difficile à mettre en œuvre pour
les communes car il n'existe pas de
convention type harmonisée la mise à
disposition qui est une convention
tripartite entre le rectorat la commune
et es reste donc un outil juridique
complexe notamment pour les petites
communes enfin le conventionnement ne
règle pas la question du coût pour les
communes et pour les établissements
privés sous contrat je signale
d'ailleurs qu'au moins une académie
applique des frais de gestion de 5 %
pour la mise à disposition d'un ESH à
une commune au regard de cette situation
confuse que tous les acteurs s'accordent
à faire à faire évoluer notre collègue
Cédric a donc déposé cette nécessaire
proposition de loi qui vise à transférer
à l'état la prise en charge des AES
intervenant sur le temps méridien et
c'est en considérant les impératifs de
solidarité et de l'intérêt de l'enfant
que la Commission a adopté ce texte sans
modification celui-ci réduit les
inégalités de situation entre des
enfants aux besoins comparable et assure
une continuité dans leur prise en charge
et je veux pour cela saluer nouveau
Cédric Vial pour son initiative
salutaire cette évolution législative
pose aussi la question de la formation
des aesh les 60 heures de formation sont
sans doute déjà insuffisantes et doivent
être complétées en effet les missions à
accomplir sur le temps méridien ne sont
plus axés sur les gestes du quotidien
diffèrent du temps
pédagogique je conclurai mon propos par
deux points madame la ministre je
souhaite vous alerter sur la situation
des unités localisées pour l'Inclusion
Scolaire les classes uliss les élèves
concernés sont affectés dans ces classes
par l'Éducation nationale l'école qui
les accueille peut-être située dans une
commune autre que leur commune de
résidence certains élus au motif qui
n'ont pas donné leur accord à une
scolarisation en dehors de la commune
refus de payer la prise en charge de la
ESH sur le temps
péréscolaire la situation est telle que
certains maires s'opposent aujourd'hui à
l'ouverture d'une classe ulice dans
leurs écoles en raison du rest à charge
qu'elle engendre
enfin il y a urgence à à réformer
l'école inclusive il est nécessaire de
remettre au cœur de ces priorités
l'accessibilité physique matérielle et
pédagogique et de ne pas se reposer
uniquement sur un accompagnement humain
qui ne peut pas tout mais urgence ne
veut pas dire précipitation et la
concertation de l'ensemble des acteurs
est incontournable je tiens à le
réaffirmer avec force la commission de
la culture et le Sénat se tienent au
côté de l'ensemble des acteurs pour
améliorer le quotidien des quelques
478000 élèves en situation de handicap
celui de leur famille mais aussi de leur
enseignants et de leurs camarades de
classe c'est à ce prix que nous
garantiront à chaque élève le même droit
à la scolarité et donc à l'égalité des
Chan des chances je vous
remercie merci merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Madame
Catherine V ministre du trava de la
santé et des
solidarités monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame la rapporteur Anne Valenton
monsieur le sénateur Cédric Vial
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais évidemment aborder avec vous
cette situation des élèves en situation
de handicap à à l'école et de la prise
en charge de cette celles et ceux et
j'insiste sur le Cell car ce sont
souvent des femmes qui les accompagnent
chaque jour si nous prenons un peu de de
recul nous faisons face aujourd'hui à un
véritable défi historique de notre
politique éducative notre institution a
déjà répondu à un premier sujet qui
était celui de la scolarisation de tous
les enfants de 3 à 17 ans aujourd'hui
notre responsabilité commune est de
scolariser tous les élèves de la
maternelle au lycée en prenant compte de
leur singularité et de leurs besoins
éducatifs particuliers vous l'avez dit
monsieur le sénateur Vial vous présenter
aujourd'hui une loi simple qui règle des
problèmes complexe et quelque part je
voudrais insister sur cet élément parce
que je crois que nos concitoyens
attendent de nous que nous soyons en
capacité de trouver finalement le chemin
le plus court entre le problème posé et
la solution et ce type p de proposition
de loi incontestablement va dans ce sens
alors notre école relève évidemment
différents défis celui de la qualité de
l'enseignement celui de la qualité des
relations entre élèves de la qualité des
relations entre les élèves et les
professeurs de la qualité de
l'environnement et surtout la qualité de
l'accueil de tous les élèves y compris
les élèves en situation de handicaps la
scolarisation de ces enfants implique
d'accueillir chaque élève tel qu'il est
et donc de changer notre regard sur la
vulnérabilité de voir en face la
vulnérabilité éducative car cette
vulnérabilité peut avoir plusieurs
visages mais elle est particulièrement
douloureuse quand elle provient d'un
manque éducatif car lorsque l'on ne
dispose pas des mêmes chanes pour
réussir à l'école on ne dispose pas des
mêmes chances dans la vie et lorsqu'on
laisse des élèves en situation de
handicap sur le bord du chemin scolaire
on ajoute une vulnérabilité à une autre
c'est non seulement une double peine
c'est surtout une
injustice ces enfants ont le droit comme
tous les autres de trouver leur voix
d'avoir une scolarité sereine qui sera
celle de plus de promesses et évidemment
d'une insertion plus facile la situation
des enfants en situation de handicap est
une question incontournable pour notre
école nous avons près de 35 % d'élèves
en situation de handicap de plus qu'en
2017 logiquement le nombre d'aesh a
augmenté de plus de 40 %. nous assistons
à une progression constante du nombre
d'élèves en situation de handicap
scolarisé en milieu ordinaire entre 2004
et 2022 vous faisiez allusion tout à
l'heure monsieur le sénateur Vial au
texte effectivement de 2005 les
effectifs sont passés de 100 34000
élèves à
430000 soit une hausse de 220 % sur la
période ce qui veut dire très
concrètement que ces aesh sont devenus
par leur nombre le deeme métier de
l'éducation national c'est pour
reconnaître leur rôle essentiel dans
l'école inclusive que je le rappelle
notre gouvernement a revaloriser leur
salairirees entre août 2021 et janvier
2024 leur rémunération à progressé en
moyenne de 26 % ce qui en valeur absolue
représente 200 € nets de plus par mois
nous sommes évidemment toujours en phase
avec cette loi de 2005 pour l'égalité
des droits et des chances et votre
proposition de loi vise à apporter
davantage de lisibilité dans les
modalités des AES en ce sens elle
peut-être un premier pas vous l'avez dit
Madame la rapporteur mais doit
nécessairement s'accompagner par une
réforme de plus grande ampleur sur les
modalités de prescription elle doit être
concertée par tous les acteurs concernés
garantir la continuité de
l'accompagnement humain de ses élèves
sur toute la journée d'école c'est une
nécessité pour permettre une scolarité
sereine et efficace un nouveau pas ou un
pas supplémentaire vers l'inclusion pour
les élèves le service public ne peut se
faire en pointiller il doit être en
continu car c'est la continuité qui
suscite la confiance et c'est la
confiance qui est la base de tout
partour de tout parcours scolaire digne
de ce nom merci monsieur le sénateur
pour cette initiative vous l'avez dit
par son efficacité elle va favoriser le
bien-être et la réussite de tous les
élèves dans leur diversité c'est
précisément le cœur de l'action de notre
gouvernement et je reste déterminé à
participer à cette construction d'une
école inclusive juste et exigeante pour
tous cela rejoint une conviction
profonde qui guide le gouvernement dans
son action pour l'école la réussite
n'est pas simplement une question de
résultat il n'y a pas de réussite sans
sérénité c'est notre devoir de l'assurer
pour chacun de nos élèves c'est notre
devoir d'assurer cette école de
l'épanouissement s'il y a de nombreux
sujets qui peuvent diviser celle du
bien-être et de l'épanouissement de
chaque élève ne peut que nous rassembler
et je dirais plus large ement que ce
combat d'une société inclusive me tient
particulièrement à cœur dans ce
ministère mon ministère qui va des
premiers au derniers jours de la vie qui
accompagne toutes les vulnérabilités et
les épreuves de la vie qui valorise tous
les métier de la vie le soutien en
personnes en situation de handicap sera
une priorité absolue nous le savons le
chemin vers une école pleinement
inclusive est encore long mais je sais
aussi que nous avançons dans la bonne
dire dire et comme vous l'avez dit
Madame la rapporteur cette proposition
constitue certes une première étape mais
un des éléments clés que vous avez
largement souligné c'est celui du
financement et avec cette proposition de
loi demain le financement sera pris en
charge à 100 % par l'État et je dois
vous dire que l'État regardera ce texte
avec une sagesse très
bienveillante
merci dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à Monsieur Gérard laec du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologique
kanaki monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission chers collègues la question
de l'école doit la mer de toutes les
batailles et l'école inclusive en est
partie intégrante
or la création des 4500 postes d'Es qui
constitue une disposition significative
du projet de loi de
financeces ne règle évidemment pas tous
les problèmes notamment ceux relatif à
l'emploi des accompagnements des élèves
et cela pour plusieurs raisons
premièrement l'instabilité
professionnelle de ces catégories lié au
leur statut souvent contraint
d'effectuer des CDD sur plusieurs années
deuxièmement leur rémunération les as se
voient majoritairement proposer des
contrats de 24 heur par semaine la durée
de scolarisation d'un élève donc de
maternelle et de primaire qui
conditionne ce temps
d'emploi ce temps de travail équivaut à
peu près à 60 % d'un temps plein ça fait
une rémunération mensuelle de l'ordre de
800 € par mois et il faut reconnaître
que cette précarité concerne
majoritairement les des femmes puisque
cette profession est à 90 % féminine
enfin je pointerai aussi le manque de
formation il est vrai qu'avec 60 he par
semaine il est compliqué de pouvoir
exercer pleinement je dirais la
compétence professionnelle qui est
attendu de ces
catégories cependant la PPL qui nous est
proposé évidemment n'a pas la prétention
de
l'exhaustivité et ne prétend pas traiter
emble du sujet de l'école inclusive ni
celle du statut des
absh ce texte ne constitue au fond
pardonnez-moi chers collègues mais
qu'une résolution d'un problème
découlant d'un cadre réglementaire qui
par exemple ne traite pas de manière
identique le temps méridien et le temps
périscolaire désormais les av seront
donc en en nombre et vous avez bien
voulu le rappeler madame la ministre la
deuxème catégorie au fond en nombre de
de l'éducation nationale après les
enseignants aujourd'hui toutes les
catégories de collectivités les communes
les catégories
elles-mêm étai en attente et sont
toujours en attente de clarification et
d'élaboration d'un cadre général
cohérent et nous ne parviendrons pas à
un règlement positif du problème par
passez-moi l'expression des bricolages
successifs nous avons les classes ULIS
dans le cadre de compétence se trouve
exclusivement placé sous l'autorité de
la commune qui abrite la classe mais il
ne demeure pas moins que cette classe
accueille des élèves des communes
voisines parfois nous avons des
rectorats qui consentent des mises à
disposition de ces personnels mais qui
les refacturent aux communes nous avons
un vide juridique pour les
établissements privés sous contrat cela
a été rappelé à
l'instant donc le texte qui nous est
proposé constitue un
moyen simple clair de régler la
situation confuse en mettant l'État en
situation donc de prendre en charge ce
temps méridien pour les av àche cela
étant ce texte doit être la première
étape d'un débat de fond sur la question
notre groupe politique et grâce au
travail notamment de ma collègue Michel
Grum est allé un peu plus loin que cette
proposition dans le travail
d'exploration qu'elle a bien voulu
conduire
il faudra également régler la question
du statut des abash qui aspirent à être
intégré dans la catégorie B de la
fonction publique mais en l'état nous
considérons que ce texte constitue une
disposition concrète simple pour
résoudre un problème concret et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous le
voterons
merci la parole est à Monsieur Bernard
fialer du groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
cher
collègués
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame le rapporteur et Cher
Cédric BIAL auteur de cette PPL on va
pas faire durer le suspense insoutenable
le groupe RDSE votera ce texte parce que
nous saluons la proposition de Cédric
Vial et le travail de la rapporteur Anne
vantalon pour proposer une solution à la
situation ambigue des élèves qui
requièrent un accompagnement par aesh
sur le temps
méridien les auditions ont révélé des
disparités d'accompagnement entre les
communes entre l'enseignement public et
privé qui contredisent l'égalité de
traitement des élèves en situation de
handicap selon leur lieu d'habitation ou
de
scolarisation cela n'est pas acceptable
alors une sagesse africaine dit qu'il
faut tout un village pour éduquer un
enfant et une sagesse rurale contraire
bien de chez nous dit que chacun son
métier et les vaches seront bien gardés
alors madame la ministre il est temps de
remettre de l'ordre et de placer
l'intérêt des enfants au centre de nos
préoccupations plutôt que de se perdre
dans des polémiques de
compétences que l'État par l'Éducation
nationale reste le maître de
l'enseignement que les communes
continuent à accueillir l'accueil
assurer l'accueil l'entretien des locaux
le recrutement des ASEM et
l'organisation du périscolaire avec
leurs intervenants et leurs associations
locales et que les départements par leur
compéten assument le médicosocial mais
tout le
médico-ocial la PMI examine des pistes
les handicapes jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans
alors expliquez-moi madame la ministre
la plusvalue d'une médecine scolaire
faméque en effectif pour prendre le
relais dans le suivi des enfants après 6
ans la la santé ce n'est pas que la
médecine c'est le bien-être physique
psychique et social des individus et la
part du sanitaire n'y contribue qu'à 20
%. la santé scolaire a davantage besoin
de psychologue d'assistance sociale que
de médecin et d'infirmiers pour
dispenser des soins ce sont les MDPH les
maisons départemental qui évaluent les
besoins d'accompagnement par les aesh
des élèves en situation de handicap
alors de nons au département la pleine
compétence dans ce
domaine confions-leur le recrutement et
la rémunération des aesh avec une
compensation financière par la CNSA par
une péréquation entre départements comme
ça se fait dans le domaine social et par
l'État cette répartition claire des
tâches entre l'éducation nationale les
départements les communes et même les
régions pour l'orientation et les stages
c'est ce qui se fait avec succès dans
les cités éducatives et bientôt dans les
territoires éducatifs ruraux ces fameux
TER qui n'arrivent pas à très grande
vitesse hein adoptons pour
l'accompagnement des élèves en situation
de handicap cette méthode qui fait ses
preuves pour en revenir au temps
méridien ce n'est pas un temps
anodin la cantine est nécessaire pour
les enfants des familles précaires et
nous pouvons d'ailleurs saluer
l'engagement des collectivités par leur
tarification sociale mais surtout
l'éducation à l'équilibre alimentaire
est une priorité au même titre que
l'activité physique quotidienne pour
parer l'épidémie d'obésité et diabète
qui va devenir un fardeau considérable
pour notre
société enfin Madame la Ministre il ne
faut pas que vous laissiez votre
collègue de l'éducation gérer des
situations à la fois douloureuses pour
les élèves en situations de lourd
handicap perturbante pour les autres
élèves de la classe dans laquelle ils
sont affectés et épuisante pour le corps
enseignant qui doit composer avec des
élèves porteurs de handicap trop lourd
et qui relèvent d'ime mais sont
condamnés à aller dans une école ouverte
par manque de place en
IME ces situations ne sont pas tenabl et
risque de remettre en question l'école
inclusive qui est un beau projet mais
qui réclame les moyens de ses ambitions
cette PPL le rappelle et si j'ai semblé
élargir son objet initial c'est qu'il
est urgent madame la ministre de prendre
ce sujet à
braslec merci la parole est à Madame
Samantha casbonne du groupe
RDP
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues en nous dotant d'un nouveau
texte favorisant l'inclusion de nos
élèves nous faisons un pas de plus vers
une école toujours plus inclusive et
nous ne pouvons que nous en réjouir
cette PPL que nous examinons aujourd'hui
visant la prise en charge par l'État de
l'accompagnement humain des élèves en
situation de handicap sur le temps
méridien et la traduction législative
d'une des recommandations du rapport ité
de gestion des aesh pour une école
inclusive de notre collègue Cédric Vial
que le groupe RDPI et moi-même
salu cette démarche s'inscrit par
ailleurs dans la logique de la promesse
du président de la République lors de sa
campagne de 2022 concernant les aesh ce
texte contient des dispositions
importantes pour trois acteurs les
élèves en situation de handicap les
accompagnants d'élèves en situation
euxmême de handicap et les collectivités
territoriales ayant moi-même travaillé
sur ce sujet au sein du réseau
d'enseignement français à l'étranger je
tiens tout d'abord à souligner l'avancée
de ce texte pour les élèves en effet dès
lors que la prise en charge des aesh sur
le temps méridien n'est plus assurée ou
qu'un élève est accompagné par un aesh
pardon différent sur le temps scolaire
et méridien cela entraîne une rupture
dans la continuité de l'accompagnement
des élèves en situation de handicap qui
pourtant est essentiel pour le bien-être
de ses élèves dans d'autres cas sans
prise en charge sur le temps méridien
c'est aux parents de prendre le relais
avec toutes les conséquences
problématiques que l'on peut
imaginer nous avons également pu voir
d'autres situations où certains parents
embauchent directement des aesh ce qui
en plus de représenter un coût important
pour certaines familles ne nécessite pas
de contrôle habituellement réalisé par
l'éducation
national par ailleurs ce texte concerne
les aesh et leurs conditions de travail
cette nouvelle disposition permet en
effet une simplification de leur statut
avec l'État comme unique employeur et le
lissage de leur emploi du temps avec la
possibilité de continuer à travailler
pour l'éducation nationale sur le temps
méridien nous ne connaissons que trop
bien les situations de précarité que
peuvent rencontrer les aesh elles ne
seront pas toutes résolues par ce texte
mais nous saluons cette avancée le but
premier de ce texte est donc de revenir
à la prise en charge totale de l'état
des accompagnants des élèves à besoin
éducatifs particulier comme c'était le
cas jusqu'à la décision du Conseil
d'État de novembre 2020 ce dernier avait
ainsi jugé que la compétence de l'État
en matière de maîtrise de prise par
pardon en charge des situations de
handicap ne porterait que sur le temps
scolaire ainsi la responsabilité qui
incombaé jusqu'à alors à l'État s'est
reporté sur les collectivités
territoriales pour le premier degré et
sur les départements et régions pour le
second degré cela a entraîné plusieurs
conséquences à la fois pour les aesh
pour les élèves en situation de handicap
accompagnés par ces derniers et pour les
collectivités qui ont dû assumer une
charge financière
supplémentaire ce transfert de
responsabilité entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales a pu
entraîner une rupture d'égalité entre
les élèves en situation de handicap en
ce qu'il existe des situation de prise
en charge différente selon les communes
il est en effet important de noter que
les communes n'exerçant habituellement
pas de compétenence en matière de
handicap cette nouvelle charge pouvait
être
difficile à
assurer ainsi et pour conclure je tenais
une nouvelle fois à souligner le travail
de notre commission ainsi que celui de
mes collègues Cédric Vial et Anne
Ventalon rapporteur de ce texte qui ont
permis d'aboutir à ce que donc ce texte
et ces avancées que nous salons
aujourd'hui en ce qu'il permett de
rétablir une forme de solidarité
nationale afin d'accompagner au mieux
les élèves en situation de handicap au
sein de notre école pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe RDPI votera en faveur
de ce texte je vous remercie merci merci
la
parole est à Madame Marie-Pierre mier du
groupe
socialiste bonjour monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre madame la rapporteur
monsieur l'auteur de la proposition de
loi c'est drivial je le vois plus mes
chers collègues un peu plus d'un an
après l'adoption unanime de la
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre la précarité des accompagnants
d'élèves en situation de handicap et des
assistants d'éducation je me réjouis que
nous ayons à nouveau l'occasion
d'aborder au sein de cet hémicycle le
sujet de l'inclusion scolaire la loi du
11 février 2005 pour l'égalité des
droits et des chances la participation
et la citoyenneté des personnes
handicapées qui a consacré le droit à
une scolarisation ordinaire conforté par
la loi du 8 juillet 2013 d'orientation
et de programmation pour la refondation
de l'école publique de la République qui
a pardon de l'école de la République qui
a introduit la notion d'inclusion
scolaire a profondément transformé la
prise en compte du handicap dans notre
paysage éducatif depuis 2006 le nombre
d'élèves en situation de handicap
scolarisé en milieu ordinaire a ainsi
quadruplé passant de 118000 à
478000 élèves en
2023 une concrétisation quantitative de
la promesse de l'école inclusive dont
nous appelons souvent le passage à une
logique plus qualitative et qui repose
en grande partie sur les épaules des
accompagnantes et accompagnants d'élèves
en situation de handicap en fait je
devrais insister sur accompagnant eu
étant donné que 93 % des As sont des
femmes sur qui porte vraiment la
réussite de cette inclusion elle le
porte à bout de bras j'ai à l'esprit la
formule utilisée par une enseignante
auditionné récemment à bout de souffle
comme beaucoup aujourd'hui qui me disait
sans aesh on ne tiendrait plus debout
c'est parce que leur rôle d'appui auprès
des élèves en situation de handicap est
indispensable et que l'inclusion en
milieu ordinaire ne repose pas seulement
sur le temps scolaire en lui-même que la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vise la prise en charge par
l'État de l'accompagnement humain des
élèves en situation de handicap sur le
temps méridien ce texte porté par
d'autres collègues céric Vial que je
salue et qui vient concrétiser l'une des
recommandation de la mission
d'information qu'il a mené sur les
modalités de gestion des aesh a le
mérite de revenir à l'esprit des lois de
2005 et de 2013 et au paradigme en
vigueur jusqu'à à la décision du Conseil
d'État du 20 novembre 2020 qui a dégagé
l'éducation nationale de toute
responsabilité dans le financement de
l'inclusion sur le temps méridien cela a
engendré des difficultés multiples pour
les collectivités territoriales d'une
part car toutes les communes ne sont pas
en mesure de financer ces personnels et
cela conduit à des inégalités de prise
en charge entre territoire et
établissements scolaires dans un
contexte budgétaire très contraint que
nous nous connaissons aujourd'hui la
question se pose donc avec pertinence
plus de pertinence et de
persistance d'autre part pour les aesh
pour qui la dualité d'employeur a
engendré de nouvelles contraites en
matière d'organisation de leur temps de
travail au détriment notamment de leur
temps de pause pourtant obligatoire et
bien sûr pour les élèves en situation de
handicap ayant des besoins
d'accompagnement sur le temps minien 20
à 25000 seraient concernés selon les
estimations ils sont confrontés au
risque d'une rupture d'accompagnement
entre temps scolaire et méridiens
obligeant certains parents à prendre le
relais ou à recourir à des aesh privés
voire à déscolariser leurs enfants dans
les cas les plus complexes prenant acte
de la décision du Conseil d'État le
courrier du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse du 4 janvier
202 3 au recteurs et rectrices formalise
les trois cas de figure envisageables
pour les collectivités soit la mise à
disposition par l'Éducation nationale
des aesh volontaires au collectivités ou
bien le recrutement direct d'AES par la
collectivité pour les heures
relevant du périscolaire
ou bien le recrutement d'Ash en commun
par l'État et les collectivités
territoriale si la mise à disposition
solution préconisée par le ministère
représente une avancée son application
sur le terrain s'avère complexe et très
inégale dans mon département de laadrome
il m'a ainsi été indiqué qu'à ce jour
l'ensemble des aesh intervenants sur le
temps périscolaire était recruté
directement par les collectivités cette
modalité ne règle d'ailleurs pas la
question du coûte de cette prise en
charge pour les communes principal point
d'achopement au regard des fortes
contraintes liées à la situation
actuelle nous partageons pleinement par
par conséquent l'objectif de cette
proposition de loi je tiens toutefois à
partager quelques points d'alerte sur le
coûte qu'elle représente chiffré
approximativement à 31 millions d'euros
quelle garantie avons-nous que cette
nouvelle dépense ne se fera pas au
détriment d'autres liés à l'inclusion
scolaire sur sa restriction sur le temps
méridien uniquement et non sur le temps
périsc périscolaire dans son ensemble
qui participe pourtant pleinement à
l'inclusion des élèves en situation de
handicap
je m'interroge sur la conséquence
qu'aurait l'application de cette loi
pour les aesh actuellement employé par
les collectivité sur le temps méridien
et d'autres temps périscolaires je
crains que le problème de l'emploi des
aesh sur le temps périscolaire ne se
repose très rapidement à nous nous
devons par ailleurs être vigilant à ce
que ce transfert constitue bien une
avancée pour les aesh et n'engendre pas
une nouvelle dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail je pensent
notamment à leur niveau de rémunération
certaines communes étant plus généreuses
que l'État la logique du moins1 ans ne
doit pas prévaloir plus largement il
nous faut réaffirmer l'urgence d'une
réflexion plus globale concernant
l'organisation de l'école inclusive et
le statut des personnels en charge de
l'accompagnement humain en quelques
années les aesh sont devenus la 2è
catégorie de personnel de l'éducation
nationale il est inacceptable qu'il et
elle continuent à exercer dans des
conditions aussi précaires avec un
salaire mensuel toujours endessà du
seuil de pauvreté et sans prise en
compte du temps de préparation et de
formation nécessaire au bon exercice de
leur mission dans leur
diversité ce manque de considération
nuit à l'attractivité de cette
profession en témoigne les nombreuses
vacances de poste constatées sur le
terrain nous avons pourtant toutes et
tous conscience de l'ampleur du besoin
ne serait-ce que pour satisfaire les
notifications d'accompagnement humain
émise par les maisons départementales
pour les personnes handicapées j'irai
même plus loin le ministère doit
réfléchir à la mise en place de brigades
de remplacement qui manqueent
aujourd'hui cruellement je pense ainsi à
l'exemple récemment porté à ma
connaissance d'une aage de mon
département non remplacé pendant 10
semaines de son arrêt maladie ce qui
nécessite là aussi des postes
supplémentaires il est plus que temps
pour le gouvernement de se saisir à bras
le corps du sujet de l'inclusion
scolaire aujourd'hui trop souvent source
de souffrance pour les élèves concernés
ou les personnels de la communauté
éducative avec une seule boussole celle
de garantir la scolarisation des élèves
en situation de handicap dans les
meilleures conditions possibles à
rebours de de la logique de
rationalisation budgétaire qui se cache
derrière les pôles d'appui à la
scolarité heureusement censuré par le
Conseil
constitutionnel à la suite de l'examen
du projet de loi de finances bien sûr en
gardant ces réserves à l'esprit notre
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain votera en faveur de cette
proposition de
loi
merci la parole est au président
Philippe
mouill
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
je suis très heureux d'intervenir
aujourd'hui à la fois en qualité de
prendre la commission d'affaires
sociales du Sénat mais également encore
pour quelques heures en tant que
président du groupe handicap de notre
institution et je voudrais en premier
lieu remercier et surtout féliciter
notre collègue C rivial qui parce que
rappelons que il l' très bien dit c'est
à l'initiative de ce texte d'accord que
notamment à travers son rapport nous
retrouvons une des 20 recommandations de
la mission d'information flash qui a été
réalisée par la commission culture
éducation et de la communication et qui
a été publié en mai 2023 et je sais que
je peux témoigner de sa satisfaction
lorsque lorsqu'on porte un rapport
lorsqu'on porte a conviction un message
de voir une traduction législative est
un point essentiel je souhaite également
féliciter notre rapporteur Anne vantalon
qui a bien pris en charge le dossier et
donc je vourrais vraiment la féliciter
pour la qualité de son travail en effet
comme ça a été dit il était nécessaire
de légiférer en raison d'une décision
prise par le Conseil d'État le 20
novembre 2020 qui a opéré un transfert
de la charge financire de
l'accompagnement humain des élèves en
situation de handicap en dehors du temps
scolaire de l'État vers les
collectivités territoriales non
seulement cette jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État mais connaît l'esprit de la loi
du 11 février 2005 ça a été dit qui veut
que l'État au nom de la solidarité
nationale mette en place les moyens
financiers et humains nécessaires à la
scolarisation milieu ordinaire des
enfants en situation de handicap mais
elle crée un grand nombre de difficultés
financières juridique et
organisationelle quand sa mise en œuvre
notamment pour l'ensemble des parties
intéressé c'est pourquoi la
clarification opérée par cette
proposition de loi entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales est bienvenu
et souhaitable aussi je profite de cette
tribune pour évoquer de nouveau la
situation des aesh sur notre territoire
national en effet il y a un an le Sénat
examiné et adopté une proposition de loi
visant à lutter contre la précarité des
es qui prévoyait notamment que ell
puisse bénéficier d'un CDI à l'issu d'un
certain nombre d'années de service tout
en rappelant à l'ensemble des acteurs
que il était urgent d'ériger un
véritable statut pour les
aesh malgré ses avancés le métier reste
complexe et peu attractif par conséquent
de nombreux élèves en situation de cap
ne peuvent bénéficier d'un
accompagnement faute de personnel et
cette situation la retrouve dans
l'ensemble des départements de notre
territoire national et nous connaissons
bien les raisons nous en connaissons les
causes c'est à la fois un débat autour
de la rémunération autour du manque de
formation de la complexité
administrative un sujet qui entoure le
statut des a malgré les avancées qui ont
été
réalisées je plaide moi de mon côté et
une nouvelle fois pour l'élaboration
d'un véritable statut des a mais
également pour la création d'un service
d'accompagnement global des enfants en
situation de handicap ce qui peut
bouleverser les acteurs notamment
l'éducation nationale et des
collectivités car je pense qu'il
convient de mettre l'enfant au centre du
dispositif et de prendre en
considération son parcours de vie et le
thème du parcours de vie est essentiel
dans la prise en charge du handicap
d'une façon générale un jeune enfant en
situation des CAP peut avoir besoin d'un
accompagnement le matin pendant
l'accueil pcolaire compéten communale ou
intercommunale puis pendant le temps
scolaire et la pause méridienne et enfin
le soir en garderie on voit déjà que les
partenaires les acteurs sont différents
mais il Puut également avoir besoin
d'être accompagné dans des centres de
loisirs le mercredi pendant les vacances
scolaires mais également pour participer
à des activités sportives et culturelles
en résumé des moyens multiples avec des
organisations multiples et des
financements multiplle je vous invite
donc à réfléchir à cette réflexion d'un
accompagnement global intégrant
notamment également les transports parce
que nous traitons le sujet finalement
par petit bout le point traité
aujourd'hui est essentiel c'est un point
d'organisation un point financier mais
il règle en rien finalement le je dira
l'accompagnement des enfants de
situation handicap étant persuadé qu'on
peut faire mieux avec les mêmes moyens
financiers pour un accompagnement de
meilleure qualité je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame
lordos du groupe Les
Indépendants
présent monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'arrêt du Conseil d'État du
20 novembre 2020 a suscité la
consternation des parents d'enfants en
situation de handicap comment à l'heure
où l'école inclusive est devenue une
réalité tangible peut-on refuser à un
enfant handicapé le bénéfice d'un AES
lors de la pause du déjeuner comment ne
pas être indigné d'une telle rupture de
l'accompagnement au seul motif que la
pause méridienne n'est pas considérée
comme du temps scolaire dans l'urgence
les familles ont dû s'organiser mettre
leur vie professionnelle entre
parenthèses parfois les colleés
collectivités territoriales ont été
placées dans une situation intenable
avec le devoir moral de trouver des
solutions pour que ces enfants fragiles
n'ai pas à supporter le poids d'une
décision certes fondée juridiquement
mais humainement
inacceptable plusieurs communes de mon
département leses ont ainsi dû se
résoudre à prendre financi enèrement en
charge l'accompagnement des élèves en
situation de handicap sur le temps de la
pause méridienne une charge
supplémentaire bien mal venue à l'heure
où elle se débatt dans des difficultés
sans nom pour équilibrer leur budget et
garantir la qualité et la pérenité de
leurs services certains établissements
scolaires ceux de l'enseignement privé
sous contrat ont eu la responsabilité de
trouver les financements nécessaires ou
laisser les familles assumer un coût
bien trop lourd pour elles sans oublier
les aesh ce capital humain si précieux
dont l'emploi du temps et les conditions
de travail tellement difficile et si peu
reconnu ont été bouleversés au sein des
pôles inclusivs d'accompagnement
localisés les piales la proposition de
loi de notre collègue Cédric Vial que je
salue ici à laquelle je me suis bien
entendu associé est donc
particulièrement bienvenue et permet que
soit assurée la continuité de la prise
en charge des enfants handicapés je veux
rappeler que sur 478000 élèves
scolarisés en milieu ordinaire à la
rentrée
2023 20000 à 25000 ont besoin d'un
accompagnement humain sur le temps
périscolaire ce texte met un terme à la
pluralité d'employeurs qui est devenu la
règle pour les les aesh il renforce le
droit des enfants en situation de
handicap à un parcours continu et adapté
en milieu ordinaire dans l'esprit de la
loi du 11 février 2005 pour l'égalité
des droits et des chances la
participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes handicapées il met fin surtout
à une forte de mesquinerie en prévoyant
que c'est bien à l'état qu'incomble la
solidarité nationale ce n'est pas à vous
madame la ministre c'est le Conseil
d'État donc je parler et qu'à ce titre
il lui appartient de financer
l'intégralité du salaire de du salaire
de laesh sans distinguer la nature des
activités scolairire ou périscolaire
durant lesquels ce dernier intervient
alors qu'il finance à l'heure actuelle
86500 équivalents temps plein annuel
travaillé je ne doute pas un instant
qu'il soit capable de rémunérer
l'intervention des aesh auprès des
enfants concernés sur le temps méridien
j'ajoute que la proposition de loi de
notre collègue Cédric Vial traduit l'une
des recommandations issu du rapport
d'information de la commission de la
culture sur les modalités de gestion des
eesh pour une école inclusive enfin je
ne voudrais pas conclure sans évoquer la
nécessité d'une réflexion globale sur
l'accompagnement du handicap à l'école
l'école inclusive nous le savons est au
bord de la rupture nous avons certes
beaucoup progressé sur le chemin
d'égalité l'abolition des
discriminations et la banalisation du
handicap notre regard sur celui-ci a
changé et nous voyons bien que les
différences s'estompent dans les
consciences mais si l'inclusion en
milieu ordinaire est quise les
injonctions et les incantations ne sont
pas bonnes conseillèr nous devons
imaginer dès aujourd'hui l'école
inclusive de demain l'école ne peut pas
accueillir tous les handicaps et nous
avons eu le devoir moral d'accélérer les
créations de places dans les
établissements médicaux-sociaux je pense
en particulier aux ime il nous faudra
également très rapidement mener une
réforme structurelle des conditions
d'emploi de travail des aesh nous sommes
en effet bien conscients que la loi
visant à lutter contre la précarité des
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap et des assistants d'éducation
du 16 décembre 2022 ne peut s'envisager
que comme une première étape et qu'un
acte 2 de l'école inclusive est
indispensable c'est donc avec condiction
que le groupe Les Indépendants votera en
faveur de ce texte essentiel non
seulement juridiquement mais surtout
humainement je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
anque Billant du groupe
[Applaudissements]
UC
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame la rapporteur monsieur l'auteur
de cette proposition de loi cher Cédric
Vial l'éducation nationale croule sous
les sujets importants tous plus urgents
les uns que les autres je tiens donc à
saluer nos collègues qui ont mené un
travail d'ampleur sur cette proposition
de loi son auteur notre collègue Cédric
Vial et Madame la rapporteur Anne
vantalon que je remercie pour la qualité
et la quantité des audition que nous
avons pu mener quel est le constat
depuis la loi pour l'égalité des chances
promulguée il y a 18 ans la prise en
charge des élèves par les aesh sur le
temps méridien et périscolaire n'a
jamais été traité de façon satisfaisante
et définitive l'arrêt du Conseil d'État
du 20 novembre 2020 dispense les
de prendre en charge l'accompagnement
des élèves sur le temps périscolaire
depuis 3 ans il incombe donc aux
collectivités territorial de supporter
financièrement les aesh mobilisés sur le
temps méridien d'après la DGESCO 20 à
25000 élèves en situation de handicap
seraient concernés par un dispositif
d'accompagnement sur la pause méridienne
suite à la décision du Conseil d'État
ses élèves leurs familles et leurs
établissements scolaire sont en grande
difficulté des dizaines d'enfants
d'ailleurs ont été déscolarisés le
recrutement des aesh est compliqué la
circulaire du 4 janvier 2023 qui
rappelle les trois types de
conventionnement possible ne remédie pas
à leur lourdeur administrative en
conséquence dans le 1ier et le second
degré les parents et les établissement
doivent composer avec des solutions
souvent bricolées les difficultés de par
les collectivités territoriales sont
variables d'un département à l'autre
dans cette région il n'y a pas de prise
en charge effective des élèves sur la
pause méritienne dans le second degré au
cours des auditions nous avons également
constaté les inégalités entre les
établissements publics et les
établissements privés sous contrat dans
ces derniers la seule solution pour
financer les aesh pendant le temps
périscolaire est souvent de faire payer
les familles public ou privé les parents
qui embauchent eux-même un
accompagnement pour la pause méridienne
doivent débourser 400 €. toutes les
familles n'ont pas la possibilité de
dépenser un tel montant en Loire
Atlantique une mère a lancé un appel au
secours dans les médias après avoir dû
arrêter de travailler pour pouvoir
déjeuner avec son enfant dans sa voiture
à l'heure de l'école inclusive une telle
situation est inconcevable autre
conséquence inacceptable de la décision
du Conseil d'État la mise en danger des
enfants la loi du 25 février 2008
relative à la rétention de sûreté a
élargi les possibilités de consulter le
figès aux collectivités territoriales or
les parents qui embauchent un aesh en
césu par exemple n'ont évidemment pas la
possibilité de consulter et de procéder
aux vérifications pour toutes ces
raisons des familles sont contraintes de
renoncer à leurs droits bien qu'on ne
dispose pas de données chiffré
consolidées ça a été répété souvent au
cours des auditions les auditions ont
mis en avant qu'il y a plus de non
recours que de demande d'embauche depuis
3 ans tous les acteurs sont en attente
d'une solution pour clarifier et
sécuriser la prise en charge des élèves
c'est donc avec enthousiasme que je
salue la proposition de loi de notre
collègue Cédric Vial qui entend remédier
à ces difficultés en apportant une
première réponse sur la question du
personnel le rapport sénatorial sur les
modalités de gestion des aesh indique
que 288000 élèves en situation de
handicap ont besoin d'un accompagnement
140000 AES devrai exercer fin 2024 soit
environ un aesh pour deux élèves mais
deux points sont à prendre en
considération les aesh ne sont pas
répartis de façon égale sur le
territoire le nombre d'élèves en
situation de handicap et vous l'avez dit
Madame la Ministre scolarisée continue
d'augmenter chaque année je rappelle que
l'on compte en moyenne deux à trois
contrats d'AES par élève temps scolaire
TS périscolaire TS méridien la qualité
de cet accompagnement fortement saccadée
n'est assurément pas optimale je
m'interroge par ailleurs sur le temps de
travail légalement l'employeur a
l'obligation d'accorder au salariés un
temps de pause à l'occasion du déjeuner
quen sera-t-il pour un aesh enchaînant
8h 18h avec le suivi en classe et
l'accompagnement de la pause méridienne
je tiens enfin à souligner que le métier
exercé à 93 % par des femmes demeure
précaire et peu attractif les travaux
parlementaires ont permis d'apporter une
première amélioration avec la
proposition de loi devenue loi en 2022
visant à lutter contre les la précarité
des aesh et AED cette loi est un premier
pas qui en appelle d'autres je pense par
exemple à la récente augmentation aussi
au 1er septembre 2023 de la prise en
charge des frais de transport
c'est une bonne chose mais je déplore le
manque de solutions pérennes pour les
aesh et AED exerçant en milieu rural et
qui sont laésés par ces dispositifs ma
deuxième interrogation porte sur la
formation accompagner un élève sur le
temps méridien ne requiert probablement
pas les mêmes compétences que suivre son
apprentissage en classe la formation
initiale de 60h mérite d'être musclé le
sujet de la formation est d'autant plus
important que le gouvernement entend
fusionner le métier d'AES et
desaed pour créer le métier
d'accompagnement à la réussite éducative
l'accompagnement des élèves en situation
de handicap est un métier à part entière
tout comme l' celui d'animation sur les
temps périscolaires les missions des uns
et des autres ne sont pas forcément
fusionnables ou
interchangeables en conclusion ce texte
est porteur d'une première amélioration
incontestable et nécessaire une
réflexion devra être menée sur le temps
périscolaire dans sa globalité je suis
convaincu que le renforcement et le
développement de l'école inclusive passe
par l'attractivité et la stabilité de la
loi également dans certains départements
les chiffres sont déjà encourageants en
vendz 90 % des enfants notifiés seraient
accompagnés selon la dazen mais comme le
soulignait mon collègue sénateur à
l'instant Michel Canevet le coût pour
les Collectiv
c'est 500000 € pour le département du
Finistère évidemment on comprend tous
les tous les départements ne sont pas en
capacité de le faire et ça c'est
uniquement pour le public nous ne devons
pas détruire les fondations déjà
construites mais au contraire y ajouter
des briques nous avions voté contre
l'article
53 du PLF visant à transformer les
piales en passe je me félicite que cet
article est finalement été censuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel nous aurons à
poursuivre nos travaux tout en restant à
l'écoute des acteurs du terrain mais
permettez-moi cette impertinence madame
la la ministre je déplore que madame la
ministre ouéa casterra ne soit pas
présente parmi nous alors qu'il s'agit
de son premier texte en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale
l'éducation nationale a besoin d'une
ministre et d'un ministère pleinement
engagé et entièrement
mobilisé déléguer la discussion d'un
texte sur l'éducation à vous madame la
ministre de la santé et du travail et
bien la preuve que l'école est malade en
conclusion je vous dirai le groupe Union
centrce votera avec enthousiasme ce
texte
merci la parole est à Madame Monique de
Marco du groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire
bonjour monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre monsieur l'auteur madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues avant
même la création d'un ministère
éléphantesque et les rebondissements
successifs de l'affaire
Stanislas la majorité présidentielle
essit déjà un premier échec concernant
l'éducation nationale je pense à la
ttive tentative de réforme de l'école
inclusive et à la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel du 28 décembre sur la
loi de finance 2000
2024 par cette décision les Sages ont
censuré l'article 53 de la loi dont
l'objet était de remplacer les pôles
inclusifs d'accompagnement localisés les
piales par des pôles d'appui scolarisés
les passes comme nous l'avions dit à
votre successeur sur tous les bans de
cette assemblée madame la ministre cette
réforme était dépourvue de lien direct
avec l'objet de la loi de finance elle
aurait nécessité un projet de loi à part
entière une étude d'impact spécifique et
que nous parlementaires puissions
conduire les auditions mais l'article
qui a été réintroduit par le 493 devant
l'Assemblée
nationale quoi qu'il en soit où en
est-on aujourd'hui dans tous les
territoires la mise en œuvre chaotique
de l'école inclusive a généré d'énormes
frustrations frustration des enseignants
privés de formation approfondie pour
acquérir des outils pédagogiques
nécessaires pour accueillir en classe
des élèves à besoins éducatifs particuli
frustration des parents d'élèves
constatant les difficultés à faire
respecter les décisions de besoins
d'accompagnement des commissions des
droits et de l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées frustration des
collectivités territoriale qui se voit
obligé par une décision du Conseil
d'État de prendre en charge cette
politique nationale à partir de 2020 et
bien sûr frustration des accompagnantes
et des accompagnants recruté dans des
conditions extrêmement
précaires une loi d'origine
parlementaire est venue apporter
quelques améliorations à leur statut en
2022 pour leur permettre d'obtenir plus
rapidement un CDI des progrès restent à
faire à la rentrée dernière seulement un
accompagnant sur de était protégé par un
contrat à durée
indéterminée ce métier qui est devenu le
deuxè d'éducation nationale ne dispose
pas de statut ni souvent de fiches de
poste une formation spécifique et la
revalorisation de leur taux horaire
serait
nécessaire dans certaines collectivités
des élus ont pris le à bras le corps et
propose aujourd'hui des formations et
des rémunérations à cette mission
d'accompagnement humain on peut ainsi
résumer les choses en matière d'école
inclusive le gouvernement a jeté des
grandes idées en l'air et nous
parlementaire tentons d'en recoller les
morceaux c'est également le cas de cette
proposition de loi de cédri Vial et du
groupe les républicains qui vise à
paliier les limites d'un système de
financement flou concernant
l'accompagnement du tempéris scolaire je
ne crois pas qu'il s'agisse d'un
problème de pilotage de la politique
d'inclusion ni que les moyens humains
soient
surabondants je pense au contraire que
dès sa conception les besoins pour la
mise en œuvre de cette politique ont été
sous-estimés que ces besoins sont
essentiellement humains s'agissant de
politique éducative et qu'ici comme
ailleurs le gouvernement tente de faire
porter le coup de son orthodoxie
budgétaire aux collectivités
territoriales
les collectivités n'ont pas apporté la
responsabilité du politique national il
AC moin à se voir imposer des
compétences nouvelles par un ministre
contractualisant avec desécoles
catholiques n'était-ce pas ça le sens du
protocole d'accord sur la mixité signé
en mai
2023 les collectivités doivent en
revanche garder la liberté de participer
à l'amélioration des conditions de
travail des accompagnants et des
accompagnantes nous avions déposé des
amendements dans ce sens au-delà de
cette réserve nous voterons pour ce
texte merci la parole est à Monsieur
Christian bouyen du groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègue cette proposition de loi
de notre collègue Cédric Vial elle est
de bon sens elle s'impose même dans les
conséquences négatives de la décision du
Conseil d'État sont de plus en plus
perceptibles graves voire inacceptables
il faut en effet souligner localement
des inégalités d'accompagnement du fait
d'absence plus ou moins prononcée de
capacité à gérer ces situation qui se
présente notamment sur le plan
budgétaire mais pas seulement il est
nécessaire de revenir à un disposi
positif par lequel l'État témoignera de
sa vraie volonté de considérer les
collectivités locales comme des
partenaires en tenant compte de leurs
difficultés particulièrement dans la
ruralité ce ne sera qu'un début qui ne
règlera pas tout et nous invite au
contraire au plus vite à un travail
attendu sur l'évolution du statut et des
conditions de travail des aesh pour
rendre le métier plus attractif sur la
formation renforcé de ces es par exemple
sur l'aide au repas qu'il faut dans
certains cas aller jusqu'à après réander
sous un angle presque médical sur
d'autres sujets nombreux qui tiennent à
l'école inclusive dans sa globalité
s'agissant de la pause méridienne
particulièrement pour ces enfants
relevant d'un handicap les acteurs de
l'éducation sur le terrain affirment
qu'elle fait bien partie intégrante de
la scolarité dans un système qui se veut
inclusif alors depuis septembre 2020
certaines collectivités ont pu adopter
des conventions lorsque redisons-le elle
dispose de l'ingénierie permettant de
s'engager dans cette formule mais comme
la souligné notre rapporteur Anne
Ventalon l'expérience montre que cette
formule peut faire peser un vrai risque
sur les élus locaux car le transfert de
l'autorité de gestion peut entraîner
celui de la responsabilité en cas
d'accident oui depuis 2020
progressivement la situation devient
anxiogène angoisse des familles qui
suite à la notification de la MDPH ne
vont pas toujours jusqu'à activer cette
possibilité de bénéficier de cette aide
aesh sur le temps méridien tant elle
mesure l'impossible équation à résoudre
pour leur commune angoisse des élus
locau évidemment car il est bien
douloureux pour eux de ne pas pouvoir
participer à cet élan pour une école
plus inclusive d'ailleurs reconnaissons
qu'ils apportent déjà une part
importante essentielle à cette
perspective d'inclusion lorsqu'ils
engagent de lourds travaux
d'accessibilité de leurs établissements
angoisse des enfants eux-mêmes déjà
fragilisé et qui ne peuvent comprendre
le mécanisme qui leur interdit de
bénéficier de ce qui pourrait
sensiblement améliorer leur bien-être
c'est bien pourquoi il convient que
l'État se pose en facilitateur pour que
ses enfants trop souvent en souffrance
bénéficient d'un acc accompagnement à la
hauteur de la belle ambition d'une école
toujours plus inclusive et sur l'aspect
budgétaire au cœur du problème posé je
veux aussi souligner combien cette
dépense ne peut ne doit incomber au
département au travers de la PCH ne peut
parce qu'au-delà de la notion d'aider
l'enfant dans les geste du quotidien qui
correspond c'est vrai aux attendus de la
PCH c'est bien plus d'éducation dont il
est question au même titre que la eeh ne
doit pas sachant que ces enfants
bénéficiant de laes ne rempliraient pas
tous les critère d'admission à la PCH et
qu'en plus il ne s'agit pas d'une aide
pour le domicile ne doit pas parce que
si la
compensation au Département des dépenses
d'Es les allocations individuelles de
solidarité est globalement très
insuffisante c'est bien dans le domaine
du handicap qu'elle est la plus basse 30
% de compensation seulement cette charge
ne relève donc pas des départements et
on pourra juger mon alerte sans
fondement mais d'expérience sur le long
terme je pense qu'il sera tout de même
important de rester très vigilant à
attentif j'en reviens à l'essentiel pour
réaffirmer combien il me semble
impératif de corriger une approche que
l'on peut considérer comme négative sur
ce sujet fondamental qui est celui d'un
parcours scolaire véritablement inclusif
je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
els Joseph du groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues voilà un texte important qui
peut sembler convenu au regard de son
contenu mais essentiel au regard du
nombre d'élèves en situation de handicap
scolarisés et qui ne cesse d'augmenter
un texte bienvenu pour les familles les
professionnels les accompagnements des
élèves en situation de handicap et les
collectivités local la société dans son
ensemble un texte destiné à apporter une
avancée capitale dans la vie scolaire
le handicap reste évidemment une épreuve
je veux saluer toutes les familles qui
ont un ou plusieurs enfants en situation
d'handicap qui font beaucoup d'efforts
et déploie des sacrifices considérables
dans leur vie c'est l'honneur de notre
société de les aider et de les
accompagner cet investissement humain
fait honneur à cette exigence d'humanité
qui continue à nous habiter car le
handicap est un domaine où la solidarité
nationale est naturellement appelé à
être exercé c'est à l'État que revient
le soin d'appuyer celles et ceux qui
sont confrontés à cette situation car ce
sont des charges des exigences qui
excèdent celles d'une vie ordinaire dans
une décision du 20 novembre 2020 le
Conseil d'État avait estimé que la
responsabilité de l'éducation nationale
devait être écartée dans le financement
des emplois relatif à l'accompagnement
humain des élèves en situation de
handicap sur le temps méridien cette
jurisprudence a eu pour conséquence de
compliquer la vie des parents mais aussi
celle des collectivités locales qui se
sont retrouvé confrontés à la nécessité
d'assurer ce financement de la es elle a
aussi entraîné des ruptures dans les
parcours des jeunes en raison de cette
jurisprudence les collectivités locales
se sont retrouvé à devoir intervenir
financièrement alors que leurs
ressources sont déjà limitées et
qu'elles sont abondamment sollicitées
comme on l'a vu encore récemment c'est
un goulot d'étranglement
supplémentairirees sans parler des
modalités d'application qui varient
selon les écoles certaines devont
supporter des charges plus lourdes que
d'autres au final c'est une inégalité
qui pèse sur des milliers de familles en
plein désarrois je rappeler les défis
que de nos collectivités locales sur
lesquelles on se décharge un peu trop
facilement quand il s'agit du soin de la
santé ou de l'accompagnement je n'oublie
pas les difficultés que cela succite
dans la pratique en particulier mais pas
que il y a aussi les établissements
privés sous contrat mais pour tout le
monde des emplois du temps à réorganiser
appel à des volontaires des multiples
contrats de travail et surtout un nombre
d'accompagnants qui se multiplie parfois
pour un même élève entraînant inconfort
et angoisse pour cette raison je me
réjouis que soit reconnu dans le code de
l'éducation le Prin principe de la
rémunération à la charge de l'État du
personnel affecté à l'accompagnement des
élèves en situation d'handicap sur le
temps scolaire et sur le temps de pause
méridienne je me réjouis aussi de cette
précision complémentaire également dans
le code de l'éducation pour les
accompagnants qui seront rémunérés sur
le temps scolaire et sur le temps de
pause méridienne c'est aussi une
clarification importante pour les
familles une clarification non seulement
dans le texte mais aussi dans l'esprit
de cette loi majeure qui est la loi ça a
été évoqué à plusieurs reprises ce soir
la loi sur le handicap de février 2005
et je salue à cet égard le travail de
Philippe Bas qui à l'époque s'était
impliqué comme ministre des Affaires
sociales en effet ce texte majeur
mettait à la charge de l'État
l'organisation de la scolarisation des
élèves en milieu ordinaire or la
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État apporté
une certaine dissonance dans cette
cohérence que nous voulions corriger en
matière de handicap je ne jette pas la
pierre au juge administratif il a voulu
appliquer le droit existant mais c'est
l'occasion de rappeler que dans ce type
de discordance c'est au législateur
qu'il revient d'agir parce qu'il a la
légitimité pour parler au nom des
citoyens afin de corriger les effets
d'une jurisprudence problématique c'est
peut-être quelque chose que nous serons
appelés à renouveler dans tous les cas
où les décisions de justice nous
paraîtront insatisfaisantes ou
inadaptées je me réjouis également du
rôle de la Commission de la culture elle
a signalé ce problème et à rappeler les
difficultés de notre cadre législatif
qui compromet ainsi les missions de
l'État je salue à cet égard mon collègue
Cédric Vial qui dans son rapport du 3
mai 2023 avait rappelé la difficulté
pour l'éducation nationale à répondre
aux enjeux de massification de l'aide
humaine et d'accessibilité de nos écoles
nos écoles doivent être inclusives dans
le bon sens du terme ce constat a
débouché sur une proposition de loi
largement cignée qui démontre que le
Sénat est une nouvelle fois la chambre
des territoires qui peut relayer avec
réactivité les demandes de nos
concitoyens celles des parents en
difficulté nous ne sommes pas une maison
opaque dont les sujets seraient
déconnectés de ce que vivent les
Français je remercie ma collègue Anne
Ventalon pour son travail au sein de
notre commission qui a défendu le texte
qui qui nous est soumis et qui a été
adopté à l'unanimité mes chers collègues
cette problématique n'est pas que
financière ou matérielle elle touche à
l'humain à la place que nous accordons
au plus fragile c'est au fond une part
de nous-mêm qui révèle ce que nous
sommes comment ne pas se souvenir de ces
propos du général de Gaulle à l'égard de
sa fille qui était atteinte d'une
trisomie Anne m'a aidé à dépasser tous
les échecs et tous les hommes le
fondateur de nos institutions nous
rappelle aussi que la 5e République
c'est aussi ce devoir permanent
d'humanité parce que je me félicite de
ce pas important je vous invite à voter
ce texte qui qui fait
consensus
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close nous passons à la
discussion du
texte ministre ah oui madame la ministre
avant avant avant de
passer merci monsieur le Président sans
sans allonger les débat si vous me le
permettez je voudrais juste répondre à
quelquesunes des orateurs qui ont pris
la peine de bien vouloir commenter cette
PPL et l'avis donc beaucoup d'entre vous
on sont intervenus sur la
rémunération de ces as monsieur laelec
est venu sur le sujet madame Monier en a
parlé monsieur mouiller également je
crois que sur ces éléments je voudrais
également citer Madame De Marco qui est
intervenue sur le sujet et rappeler que
effectivement il y a eu un effort depuis
2021 200 € de plus par mois et et ce qui
veut dire 26 % d'augmentation je suis
consciente que ça n'explique pas tout
que ce n'est pas la fin de tout mais
c'est en tout cas un signe que je
souhaitais mettre en avant je voudrais
dire au sénateur filer combien j'ai
trouvé intéressant l'idée qu'il a mis en
avant sur effectivement cette notion de
santé scolaire et sur la santé scolaire
je prends devant vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs un engagement
qui est le lien entre l'éducation et
bien évidemment le ministère qui est le
mien car oui nous avons un sujet alors
on le sait tous nous avons mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs un sujet de
médecin on va pas se mentirin nous
connaissons tous les clos les
conséquences du numérus clausus il nous
faut du temps pour évidemment reformer
des médecins pour autant travailler sur
le sujet apporter des solutions je pense
que c'est un impératif et c'est en tout
cas l'un des sujets que je veux
travailler très rapidement je voudrais
aussi dire combien je partage votre
analyse sur l'équilibre alimentaire
parce que effectivement la prévention
est un sujet pour tout le monde et bien
évidemment c'est important pour ces
enfants situation de handicap comme pour
tous les enfants et s'assurer
qu'effectivement l'heure du repas est un
moment où on fait attention et qu'on les
aide à se nourrir correctement procède
incontestablement de leur bien-être et
c'est pour cela que je souhaitais
insister sur le sujet évidemment j'ai
bien noté également le commentaire qui
est revenu à plusieurs reprises sur les
places en IME alors là-dessus on a
plusieurs sujets on va se dire que il y
a un sujet sujet financier évidemment
mais il n'y a pas qu'un sujet financier
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
avons un sujet de formation et très
concrètement et je réponds de façon
toute aussi impertinente à madame la
sénatrice puisqu'elle m'a permis d'aller
sur ce registre et chère Madame billon
je veux dire que c'est pas si mal
d'avoir le ministre du Travail qui soit
à vos côtés parce que je pense que la
forme etant plus le ministre des
solidarité parce que la formation dans
le secteur de la solidarité me paraît un
point majeur bien sûr il y a
l'attractivité qui est la reconnaissance
financière mais au-delà de cette
reconnaissance sonnante et tribuchante
il y a la perspective de carrière
comment nous aidons celles et ceux qui
s'engagent dans ces domaines à pouvoir
évoluer la formation est l'une des
réponses absolument indispensable donc
vous voyez le continuum gouvernemental a
aussi son importance permettez-moi ce
clin d'œil je voudrais également bien
sûr dire combien je comprends et j'ai je
voudrais souligner ce qu'a dit le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales sur cette notion finalement
d'un service d'accompagnement autour de
l'enfant qui est au centre du dispositif
je crois que cette notion de parcours de
vie avec des réponses plurielles me
paraisse un élément important et c'est
il est d'autant plus important qu'il
répond également à l'attente des parents
elle vient
vient de le dire il y a un instant
mettons-nous à la place de ces pardon je
cherche vous cherchz madame la sénatrice
très concrètement nous voyons bien la
pour ses parents de la multitude
d'intervenants et je crois qu'il est
important qu'on puisse effectivement
avoir des là-dessus un accompagnement
des familles Lure D'cos insistait elle
aussi sur la réflexion globale de la
prise en charge du handicap à l'école
avec les collègues de de l'éducation
nationale je crois que là encore c'est
une réflexion jusqu'où va l'école
inclusive ça a été mis en avant à
plusieurs reprises autre côté pensons
aussi aux familles qui cherchent à avoir
le plus d'inclusion nous sommes dans le
domaine de l'humain je pense que ça
nécessite doité écoute et respect que
c'est évidemment quelque chose
d'extrêmement
important je reconnais l'expérience du
président de conseil départemental qui
était Christian bruyen il n'y a pas très
longtemps nous étions sur le même
terrain de jeu si vous me le permettez
monsieur le sénateur et je crois
qu'effectivement à avec cette
proposition de loi il y a là une réponse
concrète en matière d'accompagnement
financier qui était tout à fait
intéressante et je pense comme vous que
c'est également un acte d'éducation que
cette capacité d'accompagner les enfants
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
répète une fois encore que le
gouvernement aura un avis de sagesse
très
accompagnante
merci nous passons à la discussion du
texte
je suis saisi d'une demande de parole la
parole est à Monsieur Max
Brisson merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre la soirée est
consensuelle et c'est bien normal vu le
sujet cela dit j'ai lu l'article 1er
avec beaucoup d'attention et j'ai
surtout lu l'article L
21-8 que l'article prer amende et je n'y
ai entendu parler que d'éducation et je
trouve une excellente chose d'ailleurs
et je veux en féliciter cette rivial
puisque les Aes désormais vont être
listés dans les personnels de
l'éducation qui sont financé par l'État
excusez du peu avec les personnels
d'administration avec les personnels
d'inspection avec les
personnels avec les professeurs exerçant
dans les collèges et les lycées et
d'ailleurs cet article aussi parle de
dépenses de fonctionnement à caractère
pédagogique qui sont à la charge de
l'État et puis aussi des droits de
reprographie des document usage
pédagogique bref cet article est
profondément pédagogique profondément
éducation nationale or c'est la ministre
du Travail qui est au B alors vous avez
répondu de manière à ce que vous avez
considéré comme une question
impertinente de d'anque Billant donc je
vais à nouveau insisterer un petit peu
dans l'impertinence ou plutôt poser le
sujet parce que c'est vrai qu'après tout
l'école inclusive pourrait être aussi
abordé sous l'angle d'un partenariat
ministériel mais nous avons cru
comprendre lors du vote du projet drit
de finance
qu'au contraire le ministre éducation
nationale tenait à récupérer et c'était
tout le sens de l'article 53 donc moi
au-delà de l'impertinence d'adic Billon
et puisque vous êtes au banc et et
certain que pour des raisons de
cohérence de l'action gouvernementale et
pour aucune autre raison puisque vous
êtes au banc moi je vous interroge
est-ce que désormais c'est un
partenariat qui va permettre de
mieuxavant de mieux prendre en compte
les ash ou est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un
accident de d'agenda et que en vérité
c'est bien toujours l'éducation
nationale comme l'article 53 du PLF le
voulz qui va non seulement prendre la
mer mais davantage encore contrôler la
politique d'accompagnement des élèves en
situation de handicap je vous remercie
d' répondre madame la ministre
merci Madame la
Ministre répondre monsieur le Président
de la Commission à partir du moment où
nous sommes face à des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale vous savez bien
que c'est le par définition la fonction
publique je n'ai pas dans mon décret
d'attribution la fonction publique
soyons je vous réponds aussi clairement
que je le peux pour autant j'ai les
solidarités et le handicap et je pense
que nos concitoyens puisque nous sommes
ici pour parler de la vie de nos
concitoyens ne cherche pas à savoir qui
est en charge de quoi mais comment le
gouvernement dans sa globalité est
capable de répondre aux attentes des
Français et c'est le sens de mon
engagement merci Madame
billon oui merci Monsieur le le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame la rapporteur et
madame la ministre je me permets de
réintervenir puisque j'ai parlé
d'impertinence tout à l'heure je voulais
effectivement relever ce cela parce que
je voulais insister sur le fait que
métier d'AES c'est le deuxème métier de
l'éducation nationale qui a des beaucoup
de problèmes dans l'éducation nationale
les statistiques et les nombreuses
intervention et proposition de loi
d'initiative sénatoriale le démontre
mais à côté de ça je voudrais aussi vous
remercier Madame la Ministre parce que
vous nous avez écouté au cours de la
discussion générale c'est normal mais
c'est pas toujours le cas et vous nous
avez répondu individuellement donc pour
cela je tiens à vous remercier
sincèrement puisque c'est vrai que on on
débat très régulièrement souvent pendant
la discussion générale nous avons des
ministres ou même des collègues qui
peuvent vaquer à d'autres occupations et
j'ai apprécié votre écoute et votre
réponse et la qualité des réponses des
démontre que vous auriez pu
effectivement peut-être le le les
ministères XXL peuvent peut-être être la
solution cher
max madame
gâel la ministre monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur merci à Cédric Vial
pour cette proposition de loi qui a
toute sa pertinence moi j'aurais parler
un peu de de l'effet sur les
collectivités merci madame la ministre
d'avoir porté beaucoup d'attention euh à
ce sujet qui nécessite effectivement que
toute la société euh se rassemble pour
les enfants dit en Afrique il faut tout
un village pour prendre en charge les
enfants il faut toute la société
éducation nationale les uns et les
autres alors moi j'ai une observation en
matière de continuité de cohérence
aujourd'hui euh ce sont les MDPH donc
les départements qui font les
prescriptions d'accompagnement des
enfants mais ces prescripteurs qui
veillent à donner le maximum
d'accompagnement aux enfants parce qu'on
sait la tenstion des familles la
pression vous l'avez dit ne sont pas les
payeurs et donc on a un problème souvent
difficile pour l'éducation nationale et
pour les collectivités puisque'au mois
d'août la MDPH peut prescrire des
mesures extrêmement conséquentes il y a
plus de budget dans mon département d'î
Villen où l'école inclusive fonctionne
bien on est amené aller chercher à la RS
des fonds qui sont dédiés aux éepad pour
l'école inclusif donc moi je pense
madame la ministre qu'il faudra qu'on
s'interroge sur la cohérence du
prescripteur qui ne peut pas ne pas être
le le payeur deuxème point très
rapidement monsieur le Président ça
concerne les écoles privées dans ma
Bretagne plus de 40 % des enfants sont
scolarisés dans des écoles privées dans
mon département il y a 40 communes qui
n'ont qu'une école qu'une école privée
extrêmement sociale sur laquelle il y a
toutes sortes de familles il y a zéro
sujet et on a un vrai problème
d'accompagnement des écoles privées sur
sur l'accompagnement des enfants et moi
je souhaite vraiment que dès lors que
l'on est sur des écoles privées sous
contrat d'association on regarde aussi
les dispositifs d'inclusion des enfants
merci beaucoup merci je vais mettre au
voix l'article 1er du texte qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 1er est adopté article 2 je
suis saisi d'un amendement monsieur
monsieur fialer
ok monsieur le Président donc madame la
ministre c'est un un amendement un petit
peu d'appel qui rappelle que l'article 3
du décret du 25 août 2000 relatif à
l'aménagement du temps de travail dans
la fonction publique de l'État qui
prévoit qu'aucun temps de travail ne
peut atteindre 6h sans que les agents
bénéficient d'un temps de pause d'une
durée minimale de 20 minutes sur la base
de cette disposition nous voudrions
soulever le débat concernant le
bien-être au travail des accompagnants
cet amendement va dans le sens des
professionnel auditionnés qui souhait
une augmentation du temps de travail des
aesh contribuant à la
professionnalisation du secteur mais le
temps de travail est particulièrement
rigoureux depuis la mise en place des
piales qui sollicitent de plus en plus
de flexibilité et et
d'adaptabilité donc cet amendement
rappelle simplement que le renforcement
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
n'est pas incompatible avec la qualité
de l'accompagnement des élèves au
contraire il participe à l'amélioration
de l'attractivité du métier l'un des
objectifs recherchés par cette
proposition de loi merci quel est l'avis
de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
ce sera un avis défavorable même si je
partage votre préoccupation chers
collègues car lors des des auditions
nous avons été interpellés par des
situations où effectivement les les aesh
enchaînent des heures sans pouvoir
prendre de de pause mais il me semble
que que le transfert de
l'état de la compétence de
l'accompagnement des élèves en situation
de handicap sur le temps
méridien est de nature à répondre au aux
interrogations que que vous soulevez
alors c'est vrai que les aesh ont en
effet un contrat unique et un employeur
unique sur l'ensemble de la journée ils
pourront donc bénéficier d'un temps de
poste dès lors que le temps de travail
quotidien atteint 6h c'est l'application
du Code du travail et pour sa part
l'amendement tel que rédigé a une portée
plus large il ouv droit à des
aménagements pour tout aesh amener à
travailler sur le temps méridien y
compris si son intervention se limite à
cette seule période soit quelques heures
par jour c'est pour cette raison que la
commission de la culture a donné un avis
défavor able quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement madame la ministre merci
monsieur le Président l'avis du
Gouvernement est le même parce que je me
permets de vous rappeler l'article 3 du
décret du 25 août 2000 relatif à
l'aménagement et la réduction du temps
de travail dans la fonction publique de
l'État puisque les aesh seront
évidemment des agents de la fonction
publique d'État aucun temps de travail
ne peut atteindre 6 he sans que les
agents bénéficient d'un temps de pause
d'une durée minimale de 20 minutes ce
cadre est prévu et mise en œuvre pour
les aesh qui intervient pendant la pause
méridienne la pause méridienne n'est pas
comptabilisée comme temps de travail
sauf si votre emploi du temps et le PPS
prévoit l'accompagnement d'un élève
pendant ce temps ce qui est précisément
le cas que nous évoquons dans ce cas-là
si vous cumulez 6 he continue de travail
au cours des journées concernées dans le
cadre de votre contrat vous bénéficiez
d'une pause de 20 minutes décompté de
votre temps de travail prévu avant ou
après le temps de restauration de
l'élève ce que je viens de vous lire est
extrait du guide ressources humaines des
AES donc avis
défavorable allez-y
monsieur bien moi je suis assez
satisfait d'avoir sensibilisé sur ce sur
ce sujet et après tout ces ses
précautions et ses annonces et bien je
retirerai mon amendement il est retiré
donc je vais mettre au voix l'article 2
du texte qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 2 est adopté je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble de la de la proposition
de loi y y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote monsieur
Vial je merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues juste un mot parce que
nous nous apprêtons à à voter ce ce
texte comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
un texte simple qui va nous permettre de
régler des problèmes devenus complexes
et Bernard fialer on a soulever un c'est
un des problèmes qui que ce texte permet
désormais de de
régler je tiens juste à ce stade si vous
me le permettez monsieur le Président à
à à remercier quelques personnes je
voudrais remercier tout d'abord Anne
Ventalon notre rapporteur pour pour son
travail efficace et et sérieux qui nous
a permis d'aboutir à à ce qui ressemble
à un consensus je tiens à remercier bien
sûr notre président Gérard Larcher et et
Bruno rotaillot pour avoir permis
l'inscription de ce texte à l'ordre du
jour de notre assemblée je vrais
remercier aussi Laurent Laffond euh et
et Max Brisson pour leur confiance et
leur soutien constant sur sur ce sujet à
mon endroit je voudrais remercier aussi
l'ensemble des orateurs de chaque groupe
politique pour leur soutien au-delà de
tout enjeu politicien et de de toute
frontière partisane merci sincèrement je
voudrais remercier également madame la
ministre pour la position qu'elle a
annoncé au nom du gouvernement et qui
marque une vision et un engagement
nouveau que je tiens à saluer la période
des vœux est encore ouverte j'espère que
vous saurez accompagner ce texte jusqu'à
son adoption à l'Assemblée nationale
désormais et j'aimais également le vœu
que le gouvernement se saisisse des 19
autres propositions formulées dans dans
mon rapport pourant portant sur les
modalités de gestion des aesh si tel
était le cas et si la méthode retenue
était un petit peu plus respectueuse du
travail parlementaire que cela avait été
lors de l'article la discussion sur
l'article 53 du PLF alors vous pourrez
compter sur mon engagement à vos côtés
pour une meilleure prise en charge des
enfants en situation de handicap obtenir
des résultats et plus d'efficacité dans
la politique d'inclusion scolaire est
une impérieuse nécessité et faire un tel
travail ensemble et en commun serait
tout à notre honneur voilà je vous
remercie et merci à
tous vous avez demandé la parole
monsieur Bisson
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je voudrais parler au nom de de
la Commission et du président la fond
qui a dû s'absenter pour indiquer que
cette proposition de loi de C triviale
est à l'origine issue du rapport de
civial avec les 20 recommandations donc
une semble bien mainant parti pour
aboutir il en reste 19 et Madame la
Ministre ce rapport et la Commission est
à votre disposition pour explorer les 19
autres commissions je pr il y a eu un
large consensus ce soir et vous avez
parlé de sagesse accompagnante voilà une
belle formule et nous espérons que cette
sagesse accompagnante permettra comme
l'a dit Cédric Vial que le texte
aboutisse au plus vite reste de vrais
sujets qui ont été évoqués en
particulier par Françoise Gatel
concernant les MDPH et les relations
avec l'ensemble de la politique
d'accompagnement des élèves des des des
élèves en situation de handicap ce que
nous n'avons pas aimé dans cette maison
c'était avec l'article 53 du PLF le fait
de voouir le passer au forceps à la
sauvette ce que nous souhaitons et nous
sommes prêts à y participer très
activement c'est que l'on remette en
effet bien à plat ce qu'a excellemment
posé Françoise Gatel tout à l'heure je
crois qu'il là un beau débat je pense
que le rapport de cériic Vial pourrait
être une source inspirante et que nous
pourrions même aller au-delà pour
trouver des solution en effet pour que
l'on ne soit pas dans ce type
d'affrontement que l'on a bien ressenti
lors du vote de l'article 53 de la part
de celui qui était à l'époque ministre
de l'éducation nationale je comprends
très bien qu'il voulait reprendre la
main parce qu'il est le payeur mais il
est évident aussi qu'il faut une bonne
articulation avec les experts qui se
trouvent à la mdphage c'est dire que la
politique de l'école inclusive
nécessitera un fort partenariat entre le
ministre la ministre d'éducation
nationale et votre ministère donc
finalement vous étiez parfaitement bien
sur ces bans vous étiez parfaitement à
votre place pour représenter le
gouvernement à l'occasion du vote de ce
texte merci mes chers collègues je mets
au voix l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi visant la prise en charge par l'État
de l'accompagnement humain des élèves en
situation de handicap sur le temps
méridien qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
la proposition de loi est adoptée à
l'unanimité
présent mes chers collègues je vais
lever la séance prochaine séance
Mercredi 24 janvier à 15h pour les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement la
séance est
levée